From motion capture to virtual production,
Disney has been able to bring everything
from the Pride Lands to
Agrabah into the real world.
But trying to translate these classics
from hand-drawn animation to live action
while maintaining
everything audiences loved
about the originals is never easy.
Like, how do you make
a photorealistic lion
that can also belt out songs?
♪ It means no worries ♪
♪ For the rest of your days ♪
To see how they did it,
take a peek at what eight
Disney live-action remakes
looked like behind the scenes.
Actress Liu Yifei
trained for three months,
about six to seven hours per day,
to portray Mulan.
Like here, where you can see her preparing
for one of the movie's epic sword fights.
According to cinematographer Mandy Walker,
the actress did about
90% of her own stunts.
The cast had to learn everything
from martial arts to horseback riding
for the action-packed film.
Meanwhile, many of the
film's gravity-defying stunts
were achieved with impressive wire work.
This film featured about
70 different animal species
created using groundbreaking CGI.
There was a key step in the process
to making sure all of the
animals looked so realistic:
facial rigging.
During this stage, animators explored
what muscles animals
have that humans do not.
By doing that, they
could ensure the animals
would do things like snarl the right way.
To make sure the animals
looked convincing when they talked,
animators used a combination
of human and animal muscles
for the characters' mouths.
Another crucial breakthrough had to do
with putting hairs on the animals.
They had to figure out the direction
an animal's hair would
move, how it clumps,
and how it interacts
with the world around it.
Perhaps most impressive is that
Neel Sethi, who played Mowgli,
acted completely alone on set,
as all the animals were created with CGI
and the other stars recorded their voices.
But he did have a little company.
Actors in blue suits and crew members
held up animal puppets
and used googly eyes on their hands,
like these pesky monkeys
that steal food from Mowgli,
which were later replaced with
CGI versions of the animals.
"The Jungle Book" paved the
way for 2019's "The Lion King."
The film was shot using
virtual production,
which allowed director
Jon Favreau and the crew
to step into the world they were creating
and shoot everything like
it was really live action.
The biggest challenge for the
film's visual effects team
was creating a photorealistic version
of the African savanna while also
remaining faithful to the source material.
Take the part where Rafiki
stands and lifts Simba.
In reality, mandrills
can't stand up like that.
So in the new version,
they animated the character sitting down
while lifting Simba into the air.
And the animals still
needed to be able to speak
and also sing some of those iconic songs.
So the animators would try to reposition
the animals' heads when they could
so the audience wouldn't be staring
directly into their mouths.
And they timed the characters'
breathing to their dialogue
and at the same time let the characters'
belly muscles and diaphragm tighten
so it would really like they were
letting out air while talking.
Many CGI dogs were created
for this live-action remake.
However, the two main stars were real.
A mutt named Monte played Tramp,
while a cocker spaniel
named Rose played Lady.
Perhaps nothing was more challenging
than filming the most iconic scene
from the 1955 original,
when the two dogs share a plate
of spaghetti and meatballs.
This scene took three days to film,
and while shooting it,
the noodles kept breaking.
So instead of using actual noodles,
they used undyed licorice
soaked in chicken broth.
This ensured that the noodle
was strong enough for the take
and also that the dogs had
something quite tasty to eat.
The moment where the two
dogs' snouts touch, though?
That was CGI.
The elephants were created with masterful
visual effects work by MPC Film.
However, the actors still needed
something on set to sell the scenes.
So an actor and a stunt
double in green suits
stood in for baby Dumbo.
But first, they had to learn
to move like a baby elephant,
which included walking around
on all fours using these stilts,
no easy feat on long shoot days.
Instead of making the Genie character
an entirely CGI creation,
Will Smith got to fully embody
him and his dance moves,
and it was all captured
by a motion-capture suit.
While "Aladdin" initially
received criticism
for how the Genie looked in his blue form,
the movie ended up having him
in human form whenever it could.
And to get a sense of some of
the film's impressive stunts,
just look at the "One
Jump Ahead" sequence.
While most movies are shot
at 24 frames per second,
some parts of this sequences were shot
at a slow-motion 36 frames per second,
while others were shot
at an incredibly fast
18 frames per second.
According to director Guy Ritchie,
actor Mena Massoud had to make sure
he was singing completely in sync.
So at some parts he
had to sing really fast
and other parts really slow.
"Mistress of Evil" is a sequel
to the 2014 retelling of "Sleeping Beauty"
from the villain's perspective.
This movie had to make
its titular character,
and many other characters, fly.
They pulled this off using
two different methods.
The first was using wires,
a more traditional practical method
for lifting up characters in the air.
The second way was lifting
actress Angelina Jolie
and the other flying characters up
with these two-pronged forks.
The forks are operated by these extras
in blue suits that you see back here,
who would later be turned
into CGI backdrops.
The fork fits onto both
sides of a person's body.
This device gives them mobility
and allows them to twist a person around
backwards, forwards, or side to side,
a "360-degree movement"
while the actor is safely
clamped into place.
Meanwhile, Maleficent's
wings were created with CGI.
While on set, Jolie
wore these on her back,
which would later be replaced with wings.
The visual effects team was tasked
with making convincing wings
and also making sure
those wings moved in sync
with the performer's body movements.
To fully embody the role of Beast,
actor Dan Stevens wore a
motion-capture suit on stilts.
The stilts ensured that the actor
was the Beast's appropriate height on set
so the actors would be
looking at the right spot.
However, they didn't
just have the characters
standing in front of green screens;
they actually built many
of these sets in England,
and they are impressive.
Take the ballroom, which was made
with 12,000 square feet of faux marble.
And they payed special
attention to the costumes.
Belle's dress was decorated
with about 2,160 Swarovski crystals,
and according to actress Emma Watson,
the costume designers created it
so it looked like it was floating
as Belle and Beast danced.
What are some of your favorite
Disney live-action remakes?
And which ones are you
most looking forward to?
Let us know in the comments.